أنت تقول أنك لا توافق وهل
تعتقد أن إسرائيل
دولة ديمقراطية أنا أدمر لديهم انتخابات لا
هذا الرجل لديه الآن ثلاث أربع محاكم
ضده بسبب أربع قضايا
فساد هذا الرجل يعرف إذا
توقفت الحرب سنحصل على كل شيء  تاريخ
بنيامين الذي ليس شخصية شعبية في
إسرائيل، هذا هو هذا
الطوف كلما تحدثت كلما
تحدثت عن الحقوق الفلسطينية أو
الوضع الفلسطيني، أنت تدعي أنه
تاريخ أنا أتحدث عن ما
يحدث اليوم، أعلم أن هذا ليس تاريخًا، هل نستطيع ذلك
نحن، لقد قلت أنك تحدثت عن
عدم رغبتك في إسرائيل إسرائيل، أنت تقول أن
إسرائيل وقعت في السابع من أكتوبر،
فأنت تضع ذلك في
سياق تاريخي، أفهم ذلك من فضلك لا
تقول ذلك مرة أخرى، ليس لدينا وقت لذلك  لقد
أوضحت هذه النقطة خمس مرات
بالفعل، لا أعرف ما الذي لديك من الوقت من
أجل محبة الله، دعني أنهي
جملة يا رجل، لا أستطيع، ربما أنت لست
معتادًا على حديث النساء، لا أعرف ولكن
أود أن أنهي جملة يا سيدي على أي حال،
لذا لا، فأنت تضلل الجمهور الآن
من خلال التوضيح أنه بقي لدي 20 ثانية،
ولن أزعج نفسي بمحاولة
الإجابة إذا كنت لا تعتقد أن
رد فعل إسراء مقبول، فماذا سيكون  لقد
كان رد فعل مقبولًا عليك، لقد
بقي لديك 10 ثوانٍ لإنهاء
الاحتلال والسماح للسلام
بأن يسود لكلا الشعبين، وهذا أمر
رائع، نعم آسف لأنك تعلم أنك
امرأة تتحدث
إلى